on this episode we get back to the cozy
confines of the fishbowl at Vayner media
[Music]
this is
ask Gary B
[Music]
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode one 94 of the ask
gary vee show it feels good to do a
normal show you know like we had the
whole show in the weird van it was a
little like a porno vibe like I was
weirded out by it I'd be lying if I
wasn't and then the London show which
was heavily thank you Matt which was
heavily Matt actually get in here it's a
good opportunity to actually announce
since I was gonna announce it Matt as
many of you know from watching daily be
on things in nature is elevating within
vaynermedia and going to our fastest
growing department will along with paid
in the video department Matt I love you
so much
say goodbye to the vaynernation you'll
not be showing up as much but I'm going
to two assistants Tyler who's been AJ's
assistant if you haven't heard AJ made
an announcement a couple of weeks ago by
the time you see this or maybe a week
ago that he's actually leaving Vayner
for some health reasons but everything's
okay but you can pick a link of that
medium Stefan for a lot of you to know
but what is a big piece of news is that
India has joined the two-person headed
monster Tyler in India tindy as I call
you guys India you are now one of my
admins Joe what do you think about this
you are yes it's going well right yeah
it's intense tell them and how and tell
them even as close as you are to me how
intense even d-roc only the people Matt
me you Nate and Playa and Phil and
cinema the historic assistants only we
really know how intense it is tell them
how intense it is in there it's so
intense like even writing your content
and like and everything I thought I knew
how crazy it was I did not write it's
even crazier like even if you guys watch
every single community and you think
it's crazy that's great it's crazier
like I literally wish one day I could
just do a video Stefan where it was just
my inbox incoming what's in there what
they don't know and and one of the
things that I'll actually say this is a
good opportunity for all the people that
watch dailyvee and if you don't
pissing me off is there's so much I
can't show because you know this I mean
think about yesterday's inbox you know
whether it's firing or making tough
decisions or firing clients or politics
there's politics not like the president
just of our internal like there's really
the heavy stuff that I eat for breakfast
cuz I love the pressure and so India I
think it is step 194 let's get into the
show alright guys I miss you I miss this
normalcy of the show we're kind of
fading out of book promotion we're gonna
be into heavy sign-up for my youtube and
and sign up for my snapchat I just
recorded but you saw this so it's the
fun you're putting out London today
later today and so you'll put this out
tomorrow's what Friday at great so a lot
of you saw yesterday that I taking over
some snapchat accounts that's fun so
building up my snapchat that's what
we're gonna be focusing so let's do it
Michael asks as a huge fan and
student-teacher I'd like to know what
you feel makes a great teacher I think
what makes a great teacher is one that
doesn't impose what they want the
student to learn but the person that
actually audits the student and
understands where to point them a
counter-puncher for say more so than
somebody who's got a strict blueprint
and whether or not you fit into that
blueprint is irrelevant I teach a Rick
I'm going to make you go down this path
and this is what you have to learn and I
think it's a huge mistake it's my
biggest problem with curriculum in
traditional schooling it does not
account for the creative the oversmart
the slightly different and what it's
trying to do is create an 80% of these
type of output workers and the 20
percent either pro or con get kind of
left along the way and so I think a
great teacher listens and a great
teacher reacts and a great teacher
deploys empathy and understands there's
other things can sniff
there's problems at home if you're in
the younger years or as an older I feel
like I'm a teacher and I feel like one
of the biggest things I try to say all
the time is I'm just telling you what
works for me please don't do I don't
tell you you have to work 18 hours a day
I don't tell you have to do anything I
tell you that this is what works these
are some theories and use the context
around that I think teachers need a lot
more listening skills and adjustment to
the reality versus how they were how
they were taught or what they're trying
to accomplish by year's end by years and
these 23 students are gonna know how to
do multiplication like it's so tactical
it doesn't feel like a teacher at all
and I and I question and I push and I
prod and I poke and I I I battle a lot
of my teaching friends of are you just
checking the box for your eight months a
year job to like get it through to hit
tenure to be in a union that never
creates any vulnerability or you try to
actually teach these kids and I hope
everybody understands I'm I'm not pumped
I'm not cynical against teachers I don't
think teachers I don't like I I think a
lot of times sometimes people want to
hear micro answers for me think like I'm
tough on teachers or this in that nature
I'm mad at the game
I wish teachers were got paid four
hundred thousand dollars a year I would
I mean I send my kids to private school
I've spent a lot of money like teachers
like I don't like the system that a lot
of people K through 12 have to play
within and I think a lot of those
talented teachers could be doing
unbelievable things and I'm so excited
to show the computer I'm so
exceptionally not that computer by the
time that actually happens I'm so
excited it's probably to be contact
lenses I'm so excited for this because
so many of the great teachers in the
world won't have to play within the
confines of the politics of the
traditional school system and will teach
be way more profitable and make much
bigger and this is the big one make a
much bigger impact on their students
lives then asks would you consider
adopting children mmm-hmm that is a real
question venom I sent that to you India
because it's been something on my mind
for a long period of time and Lizzy
would tell you this is something I've
brought up and I think she thinks I'm
joking at times and probably not as much
somewhere around five or six years ago I
had a real kind of like lightning
feeling
that I should adopt that I am exactly
the emotionally strong financially
situated person that is put on earth to
adopt and the truth is when you're in a
relationship it's a partnership and so I
can't impose my will or I want through
my needs
or I'm Lizzy without being completely
aligned on it but I have wanted to adopt
for the last five or six years and it's
something that's in me and it's
something I think about a lot I do and
I'm I'm fascinated by the whole thing
and I'm very under educated I know
there's a huge process I'm under
educated on like how many kids need it
you know I'm sure there's very big
difference but in data of like Eastern
European or Asian kid American kids poor
families minorities girls boy like
there's so many enormous ly complicated
issues but for me I don't know there's
something just in my stomach that feels
that I can help and that I'm built for
it and it's been something that's been
in my mind for a long time but I before
all the comments come in and be like you
should get Lizzy to do it like you know
like this is such a personal thing I
know I know
absolutely devastatingly awful adoption
stories personally and so I have empathy
for spouses who one wants to him one
doesn't and I don't think like I don't
think I'm the noble one or the good one
I just but but no question the reason I
sent it to you is it is something that
I've wanted to do and I've been curious
about why I think about it quite a bit
actually probably two or three times a
year I have a good think on it
and it's been an interesting pillar for
me what about one of my best friends my
best friend growing up Robbie turn ik is
adopted so I think I've been around it
and comfortable with it a long time yeah
come here thought about yeah Peter is
such that you don't you're not even
married yeah do you have any miss our
family you know and I thought about it
in my 20s like but it got interesting as
I got older
yeah it's alright Stefan you don't think
about [ __ ] huh here's the 20 years you
either been like hooking up in
basketball
Joshua I keep it simple Joshua asks if
you owned a small newspaper what would
you do with it how would you change how
it delivers news / earns revenue I would
if I owned a small newspaper I would
hopefully own one that had big brand
equity even though in a small market
right so even if it's Bethlehem
Pennsylvania if it's the Bethlehem Times
or whatever the local paper actually the
East Express isn't that their paper
there do you know the East that express
that there is an Eastern Express so if I
owned the Eastern Express that's a very
important thing in that part of
Pennsylvania and I would turn the equity
and this is where Jeff Bezos was
brilliant with possibly buying the
Washington Post he didn't he didn't buy
it for the print he bought it for the
brand and so the Easton expressed that
small area of Pennsylvania matters quite
a bit in for Lehigh Valley and I would
try to make the digital modern version I
would make an app today I would make an
app that is the absolute news app of the
moment notifications driven I would
digitize the IP but and and try to milk
the print revenue for as long as I could
but I would assume zero print print
revenue in a 10-year window all IP value
being shifted into something else same
reason the 92nd Street Y is so insane do
you know how this played out you know
how I talked about Nintendo at the 92nd
Street wine like a month later they
announced that they were gonna do it you
know a lot of people like you knew I'm
like yes I'm that wired in you know the
CEO of Nintendo is hitting me up that's
what I would do Nintendo smartly finally
has understood that they're gonna take
the IP and take it to the relevant place
that's what I would do with the
newspaper I would take the IP and I
would take it to a relevant place I
would also create revenue around event
marketing so instead of taking
advertising in my print I would take one
full page to invest in my own events
business like the like the the Fall
Festival right where and I can use the
newspaper and it's awareness to build up
this events driven business and every
year and you know in Phillips from New
Jersey there'd be a Fall Festival for
the Lehigh Valley of Pennsylvania New
Jersey area and so I would I would
siphon the waning attention and I would
deploy it into new environments like
digital content and other revenue
streams like events that was tangibly
and tactical and really maps to
everything outside you know I think of
everything in IP transferred to the
modern world not just the newspaper so
if I bought a 1980s cartoon IP the
Wuzzles I would make a Wuzzles game you
know I like Alistair yeah I don't know
Alistair yet but this is amazing what a
pause right there
Stefan cut back I'm so into this
Alistair thank you so much other people
have been doing it we need to do a good
job and make sure I'm also also debating
only going to video on the show this is
a new thing after episode 200 I'm
debating that all five questions are
only in video form video is exploding
with snapchat Instagram one-minute video
now if you haven't done it I posted one
yesterday today and and I'm very hot on
this and so keep that in mind and let's
keep the really cool settings going
alliser's Rock and this is cool did you
see next
my question for you is this you have a
team of five or six hundred people and
you're very prolific yourself in terms
of the knowledge you have et cetera how
do you ensure that the rest of the team
is speaking the same language as you and
and the same saying the same things to
clients that you would say very
interested in your answer great work
with the show keep out thanks very much
our show thank you so much one of the
toughest things to do here it scares me
to know right now somebody's on the
phone with somebody who has a slightly
wrong or off tweak on the one minute
transition of Instagram video or the new
snapchat messaging or the ability to
caption Twitter posts and pictures now
and so I'm uh I'm very I'm concerned and
come up with emailing the whole team
asking them to watch my content I'm
gonna be doing a recap of my own content
and learnings and thoughts over the last
thirty days we did an internal podcast
for a while we're trying a lot of
different hacks all hands-on meetings
breakout groups lunch and learns but the
truth is there's vulnerability because
it's a human situation and so here's a
big one I'm not crippled by them doing
the wrong thing I'm not crippled by
Ricky Magoo right now being on a call
with a client and saying the wrong thing
because it just plays itself out meaning
either we have to apologize to the
client and say look Ricky gave the wrong
advice and that's a human vulnerability
and we could get fired and things of
that nature but I I recognize the
inefficiencies in human communications
and I own them and I know that eighty
nine point seven percent of time were a
hundred percent on point you know seven
percent of the time you know we're doing
a really good job in three point three
percent of time we're not and I can live
with that and that's a net net game
that's the other day when I said speed
is better than perfection when you're
running a big company the way you get to
650 instead of nine is you don't worry
about every person having everything
exactly right plus you need to leave a
little room for them to do their thing
you know the Mark Evans and the Katy
Hankinson and the mad seagulls of the
world these are talented people Steve
Babcock my new chief creative
to talented people they need to have
their slight iterations that are allowed
to disagree a little bit with me it's
not it's not called Gary Vaynerchuk this
is vaynermedia vaynermedia is a
collective of us and so those are two
ways I actually get through that and I
think a lot of you can learn in
management and leadership from that
answer this is an interesting mark a
mark a mark asks what's one question
nobody has ever asked you that you
really wish they would you're right I
hate this question India I you know I
don't know I I don't you know I feel so
comfortable bragging and having my own
ego and Tooting my own horn because I
think that's appropriate I think you
should be your number one fan and
there's you know as long as you're
balancing it with humility and I know
people will catch you in different
moments and that's why they'll think
you're egotistical but as long as you're
balanced for yourself you know the
market will come around to you I because
I'm comfortable in you know I wish
people asked me more about the fact that
I'm not a marketing guru that I've built
big hunt tens of millions hundred
million dollar companies right but I
don't have that ask that because I say
it right like I you know like I you know
I wish people asked me more questions
about me being a good HR driven CEO and
me having a lot more humility and and
patience and kindness and empathy than
they owe but I don't need them to ask
that question because I say it and so I
don't have a want or need of any
question because most people that have a
want or need of a question is they want
to use somebody else's question as a
disguise to brag it's why we created
humble bragging right like and and I
think we should just be more transparent
guys jab jab jab right hook right so
many people love that and they learned
and they've been successful and right
give give give and then ask cleanly yet
when acting humble or acting with
bravado they want to mix it humble brag
right they want to mix it they want
people ask them questions because that's
their opening to brag a little I think
the way you talk about yourself and the
you paint a narrative to the world
should follow the jab jab jab right hook
humility humility humility ego and maybe
I'm in the jab jab right hook right hook
business and so there's equal parts of
both but I think I think that the reason
I've never wanted anybody to ask me a
question is because anything I really
want to say I'll say both pro and con
you know somebody left a comment in the
dailyvees of like whoa Gary and Mitzie
sorry a lot I guess just from the call
calls I'm sorry team or do you know like
sure like if you're gonna - you're like
if you're gonna if you're gonna amplify
your w's you have to accept your else
you know and so the reason I don't want
anybody ask me a question what's that
wins and losses yes thanks for following
along yeah walls of lollipops
that's it it's fun to be back in the
saddle I really appreciate you guys
heading home - episode 200 really
excited to wrap up the series that
episode 200 and focus on dailyvee and I
love them new people come question of
the day what is your current fascination
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]